انا اظهر اليوم من على احد اجزاء يخت
المنصور في شط العرب جنوبي البصره طبعا
كنا نروي ان نقف على سطح هذا اليخت لكن
للاسف في الرياح اليوم تجري على عكس ما
نشتهي طبعا هذا اليخت صنع في ثمانينيات
القرن الماضي في فنلندا عام وارسل الى
العراق عام 1983 يبلغ طوله 121 متر
يعني وزن يبلغ 7,000 طن تقريبا طبعا هذا
اليخت يعد واحد من اهم واضخم اليخوت التي
كان يملكها صدام حسين والتي هي تقدر
بحوالي ثلاثه يخوض تقريبا هذا اليخت كان
يرسو في ميناء ام قصر حتى عام 2003 قرر
صدام حسين رساله الى ممر شط العرب في اذار
2003 نعم طبعا خشيه على اليخت من القصف
الاميركي لكن للاسف الخطه الخطه فشلت
وتعرض القصف بعد ذلك في 2003 اليخت الى
القصف على مدى ثلاث ايام متتاليه لكن هذا
القصف يعني لم يتسبب بغرق اليخت كما ذكرت
مفتشيه اثار البصره ما تسبب بغرق اليخت هو
سرقه المضخات الضخمه الموجوده في محركات
هذا اليخت والتي ادت الى حدوث ثقوب كبيره
جدا وتسربت المياه في اليخت فبدا اليخت
بالميلان تحديدا في يونيو 2003 طبعا كما
نشاهد اليخت اليوم يعني هو هيكل صدق
ومتهالك يتواجد في يعني يقف في منتصف شط
العرب وهو اليوم يعني مزار للسياح
والصيادين ايضا الحكومه المحليه في البصره
تنوي حسب ما يقال تفكيك هذا اليخت وتقسيمه
الى اجزاء وانتشاله من شط العرب لكن هذا
الامر يتطلب مبالغ كبيره جدا جدا بالبدايه
يعني يعتبرها العراقيون فعلا جوهره ثمينه
متواجده في شط العرب المشكله ان الانتشار
اليخت من النهر يتطلب مبالغ ضخمه قد تصل
الى اكثر من المبالغ التي صرفت على يعني
صناعته فهذا ما يحول دون انتشاله بسهوله
لكن الحكومه المحليه تعمل على ذلك يعني
هنالك انباء يعني عن محاولات قريبه جدا
لتفكيك اليخت وانتشاله غير معلوم حتى الان
يعني ماذا ينمون يعني الفعل به بعد
انتشاله واخراجه من الشاطئ حاليا هذا
الامر غير معلوم لكن على بعد 500 متر من
هذا اليخت يتواجد يخت اخر لصدام حسين هو
وهي خط رئاسي اخر يعني هو ياخذ نسيم
البصره على بعد 500 متر من الان
ويعني هذا اليخت هو حاليا مركز لعلوم
البحار وهو ايضا يتضمن متحف لما
كان يتضمنه في السابق يعني لمقتنيات
الرئيس